okay let's get started welcome everyone
thank you for being here at one of the
last talks of this amazing conference
third day so you're the resilient people
right so much information and you're
still here to learn more I admire that
so my name is Lila Buria I work for a
company called particular software where
we build in-service bus and a platform
around that that is supposed to help you
in building uh distributed systems
specifically message based ones so
before I worked there I was already out
in the field building message based
systems myself and one of the things
that stood out to me is how hard it
becomes to sort of debug these systems
with messages flow around the system and
all of that and so this session is a bit
inspired by all of that pain I have seen
teams go through when they adopt
messaging including myself right so with
that being said I'd like to start off
today's session with a story
so one step at a time there was a retail
business that decided to build a sort of
online shop for their offering and they
started small but you know they were
pretty successful so as this business
business venture grew they quickly
understood that in order to keep up with
all of the changing requirements and all
of that increasing complexity that they
had to start decoupling the system into
sort of separate components that could
evolve a bit more independently and even
by different themes so slowly but surely
that sort of evolved into what we
nowadays call a distributed system with
multiple components interacting with
each other and before you knew it we had
three teams in the house team lorem
ipsum and dollar
or the way I would say it dollar with my
Spanish Roots so for those of you who
don't know dollar means pain because
there's always sort of one team that
takes a hit and is doing like the really
really difficult job right so as a way
to sort of communicate between these
components that are now part of the
distributed system they chose to use
messaging
so let's take a look at one of the sort
of most crucial business processes that
is a part of this system placing an
order and we sort of know how this works
but let's go over it anyway so we want
to sort the order and some database we
also want to make sure that we charge
the credit card so we can actually make
some money
and then we want to package the order
ship it and then also make sure that we
include an invoice for the customer so
they have some proof of their purchase
and then we also might may want to
adjust the stock based on you know that
purchase that was just completed
and also figure out whether we want to
maybe order some more stock to see you
know is this product now almost depleted
and do we need to back order it for
example
and then finally we also want to verify
the customer status to see oh was this
their first ordered and maybe they get a
discount code because that's how we can
pull them back in or maybe if they it
was their 100th order then they're now a
gold customer or something like that
so if we think in terms of these
responsibilities in in terms of the sort
of teams that we're managing them we
have Team lorem sort of responsible for
the order fulfillment part we have Team
Epsom responsible for everything
regarding the stock and team dollar
responsible for everything regarding
customer care hence the name right
so if we think in terms of the messages
that are flowing through the system to
sort of support this business process
that we could come up with something
like this so we have a sales component a
payment component and a stock component
and they all have sort of their own
commands and events that sort of support
this business process from beginning to
end
but looking at the system this way
doesn't really tell us anything because
it hides the entire complexity about how
are these components sort of interacting
with each other and who's sending a
message to who or maybe which components
are reacting to which event and how's
that evolving so in order to get a
better understanding of that we always
need to sort of draw the system in terms
of interactions which gives us a
completely different picture right
everything starts in sales make sure
that you know payments gets that payment
done and from there on we'll publish an
order placed event that is then sort of
subscribed to by multiple other
components in the system and they just
do whatever is relevant to that specific
component that they're in right the
publish subscribe pattern and one of the
advantages of doing things this way is
that we end up with sort of autonomous
components that are just reacting to
sort of events that are occurring in the
system and then doing whatever action
makes sense within that business
component
so
the that leads us to those autonomous
components and that brings as many
advantages one of them is that it sort
of allows our teams to operate in a sort
of autonomous manner what does that mean
well it means that they can evolve that
component you know following their own
planning and their own requirements but
it also means that they can choose
whatever programming languages
Frameworks and tools that best suit
their needs right that could be
different
it also means that each of those
components can operate in isolation so
given that we're also using messaging in
the system it means that if one
component is down normally the rest of
the system should be able to continue
operating without too much friction
and as long as the interactions between
these components are based on a set
contract which in our case is messaging
right they should be able to evolve
independently as well
now the thing is that anything that can
evolve independently can also fail
independently
so let's take a look at one of the
exceptions that our team ipsum ran into
so it's showing a pretty simple stack
Trace we're trying to process and update
product stock message and we're running
into an exception because we cannot find
the product that is specified in that
message input
so when the engineers on team Epsom look
at this they immediately start racing
through a bunch of questions right so
they think about what happened you know
where did it happen in which context did
it happen and why usually we'll look at
the exception message maybe see if
there's any inner exceptions look at the
stack Trace so sort of try to understand
what happened here and normally
debugging is then the next step right
because that's how we sort of build up
like a step-by-step context of how data
is flowing through the system what are
we changing what are we passing on so
that we can sort of understand what is
the root cause of this failure
now the thing is that if you're running
in a message-based system you're going
to have to ask yourself a bunch more
questions to be able to understand
what's going on
first of all you need to understand
which specific action started the
specific chain of messages that we are
seeing at this point you also need to
have a thorough understanding of which
components are basically involved in
that sort of business transaction that
we are executing here we also need to
understand which specific sequence of
measure of messages that are being sent
because that might also be different and
finally in which specific order they are
being executed and how that may have an
impact on the sort of behavior that
we're perceiving in the system
so let me take a moment and step into
the shoes of the engineer that's
assigned this issue the stack Trace that
we just looked at and you know you can
decide for yourself if I'm speaking from
experience okay
so I look at the exception message and
I'm like you know product not found okay
you know look simple enough let me just
quickly debug this
so I look at that failing message drag
it back from the area code to the input
queue start that component and boom
immediately I run into the exception so
I start looking at the state that I have
available the exception message all of
that and then I think okay let me just
take a look at the call stack to see how
I got here
the thing is that I scroll down only to
understand that I'm ingesting a message
off for queue so that's not giving me
much Insight I don't know how I got here
well that's no problem I'll just start
the initiating component that started
this entire business transaction and
I'll just take it from there and then
I'll be able to you know step into the
next method f10f11 debug through it
but that's not going to work either
because at some point we are either
sending a command or publishing an event
and that's being handled by another
component in the system
okay
you know what I'll just start the entire
solution with all of the components in
it and then I should be able to just
debug through everything
but that's not going to work either
because we decided to split everything
up into separate Solutions oh yeah and
separate file stories too whose idea was
that
okay
I know let me just start up eight
different instances a visual studio
writer whatever your favorite IDE is
I'll connect the necessary processes
together and then I should be able to
debug through everything right
should work and I'm a very stubborn
person so I'm going at this for a while
because I need to make sure that I have
all the right infrastructures set up and
all of that but I got there like a few
hours fighting with this and I'm
debugging through everything I have
157 break points set all over the place
but okay I'm looking through things and
I'm like really really close to finding
the problem like you have that gut
feeling you're like I almost got it just
just leave me alone for five more
minutes
and I think to myself okay
this breakpoint F10 F10 I should be able
to hit a five to the next break so hit a
five everything pauses for a second and
I hit another break point and I'm like
dang it I forgot another break point
at that point I have Mediterranean rules
I'm already cursing at least three
different languages I need a break it's
like okay step outside do some breathing
exercises maybe have some comment here
or something and I think to myself Lila
get it together like seriously just
debugging this how can I do this
oh I know let me add some logging so I
go back in fresh energy start adding
some log statements all over the place
and I'm looking at that information
that's being emitted still debugging
through the whole system
and I going through things and I see
order 256.
and I'm like wait a second wasn't I just
debugging order 325
is this message even mine
so I look at my colleagues and I'm like
is there anyone creating orders on the
testing environment because I am
debugging something right now so don't
touch anything
now at that point my colleagues look at
me in disbelief they're like what are
you doing are you debugging the whole
system
you know I'm gonna try I'm trying to fix
this issue
and they say well do you think anyone at
Amazon runs into a failure and thinks to
themselves oh let me just fire up the
amazon and I'll debug through this
but you know if you put it like that I
guess not
but then the question is what do we then
do instead right
well we test and if I'm stating the
obvious to you right now awesome because
testing is important independent of any
architectural style that we are using in
the system but if we're running in a
message based system where components
are interacting with each other all the
time then it's really crucial to have a
sort of strong testing strategy to
support that as well
so any testing strategies are sort of
outside the scope of this talk but I do
want to give you sort of a few things to
remember especially in the context of
testing message based systems
and I have rethinking the rule of three
what does that mean well I've used for
years AAA syntax who's ever used that
before
okay cool but there's given when then
who's used that before
right but it's all sort of the same
thing right you're preparing some input
you executed this scenario and then
you're going to verify what basically
what the system has done and whether
that sort of matches your expectations
so if you think about that in terms of
message of messaging when you sort of
prepare that test input we want to
prepare a message
and as part of executing that sort of
action we're gonna
invoke the message Handler that's going
to be responsible for basically
processing that message
but it's a verification phase where
things get a little bit more interesting
because not only do we want to verify
any desired outcome in terms of data
modifications API calls or whatnot but
we also want to verify any of the
outgoing messages that were sent or
published as part of basically
processing that specific message why is
that so important because that's how
we're doing the handoff to the next
component in the system the next
component whoever is you know receiving
that message or subscribed to that event
is going to be banking decisions based
on that information that they are
receiving there so it's really important
to check that including whatever content
that is in those messages
that's all good but you know as always
the devil is in the details right and
with the details I mean the order
so one common mistakes that we tend to
make a lot when we write code is that we
tend to make a lot of assumptions about
the state that the system finds itself
in
and the thing is that if those
assumptions don't hold up in a
production environment then your
handlers might start failing all over
the place
now that's a little abstract so let's
take a look at an example I have this
sort of naive stock update
implementation here so this is the sort
of update product stock Handler and what
we are doing is I'm looking at you know
what the message payload tells me
increase stock decrease stock and I'm
just executing that
but we also added a guard class because
you know you cannot have a negative
stock I mean who has minus 10 Place
PlayStations in stock that doesn't make
any sense
the thing is that that's an assumption
right there because is it really true
that the stock can never ever be
negative
let's walk through this for a second and
sort of zoom in into how this domain is
set up currently so the way it works now
we have that place order coming in in
sales we make sure it's paid and then
that becomes a sort of trigger to update
the stock
but imagine that you know we're it's
release day right for whatever
PlayStation or whatever thing you like
I'm not really a gamer so I don't care
as much but
um and there's so many sales coming in
at the same time and you know someone is
receiving a massive truck of
PlayStations on the other side goes in
puts that into system that's an
increased stock message right at the
same time we're selling a massive amount
of PlayStation resulting in those
decreased stocks now there's all in the
same queue right but that increased
stock message somewhere at the bottom in
the meantime we are selling it so we
have all of the stock available system
doesn't reflect it yet so it's
situations like these that could trigger
that sort of guard Clause to make the
system explode at that point
so you could say well you know we'll
just reserve the stock immediately when
you complete the sale right and although
you might be able to sort of alleviate
the problem a little bit you're not
going to get rid of it entirely it might
still happen especially if you're
running in sort of high throughput
scenarios
and you might think to yourself well
okay you know we'll just reserve the
stock whenever you put something in your
shopping basket
that's possible I've actually seen web
shops doing this but there's also a risk
to that right because I like to shop
around on Plenty of web shops put a lot
of stuff in my shopping basket does that
mean I buy all of it
no I don't think my husband would
appreciate that right so that's also a
risk so how do we solve this type of
problem then instead
well the thing is that we need to let go
of this assumption that the stock cannot
be negative and then we can start
looking at what type of scenarios that
opens up
so in this scenario we could say you
know whenever our order is placed what
we're going to do is basically send a
message to the stock endpoint and say
hey do you have this stock available if
stock says yep I have everything cool
then everything is good in the world
right and then we can just move on and
basically complete the sale if there's
insufficient stock then we could for
example do something like
okay we're going to send a delayed
message two days in the future and
basically go verify whether this sale
was now completely shipped and if not
we're going to refund that order
and this is actually a real life
scenario because a while ago while a
while ago a few years ago at this point
where we were like in the middle of
covet I was sort of shopping around for
like a big home office screen 49 inch
because reasons
and I was trying to find someone and
they were depleted everywhere so I was
just hoping to find one in stock found
one shop in the Netherlands I'm from
Belgium and it said next day delivery so
I was like okay let me just quickly
order this
and only and I was happy and then two
hours later I get an email in my inbox
saying sorry it's out of stock but you
know we're going to back order this for
you and if it doesn't arrive to your
house within two three business days
then we'll just refund your money
right if you're looking at this example
and thinking but I have five other
possible solutions sure you do I'm sure
I believe you and there's probably even
better Solutions but what I'm trying to
sort of make you think about is to start
thinking about the assumptions that you
have hidden in your code base
think how what if this doesn't hold up
in a production environment what what
effect is that going to have on the
system and could I basically be modeling
things in a different manner so that we
could just not run into this problem at
all and just handle it differently so
this is where we want to talk to our
business experts right because if you
would go with this specific scenario to
a business Expert and say well we can't
sell any stock that we don't have
they'll tell you of course we can just
sell everything we'll try to back order
or give them a voucher and then we
already have the money and they'll just
have to spend it with us right that's
how businesses work
so okay let's recap this first part
do you run into a failure do you want to
add more tests you're missing at least
one but probably more test scenarios
when whenever you run into a failure
right also assert any outgoing messages
that are being sent or published as part
of processing a specific incoming
message
and then also be very aware of the
assumptions that you're making in the
system and one of the tools that I like
to sort of use when I talk to business
experts because remember that even these
people have been sort of working with
you on a system for maybe years and they
also get stuck in their own assumptions
so sometimes it's helpful to say what if
there was no computer system at all what
if you were just running this as a sort
of physical environment just a shop and
running this with the books what would
you do and that can sort of so sometimes
give you like a completely different
perspective as well
and finally expect out of order messages
to happen they will happen like don't
put your hand in the sand it could be
concurrency retries it could be
infrastructure reliability whatever it
is we can always assume that things are
going to happen exactly in the specific
order that we expect them to
so okay our team's Lauren ipsum and
donor they took this really seriously
and they came up with a very consistent
testing strategy you know continuous
integration everything looks green
they're like okay let's go to production
we're good to go so they do that and
they've been running actually quite
successfully in production for a while
but then there's this guy Murphy that
comes knocking down their door and a
failure occurs in production
well what do we do then
failure
we add more
tests thank you just said it right so
whatever you run into a failure you add
more tests
but the thing is what if you look at
that message payload
and you think to yourself
this doesn't make any sense this data is
bogus like of course this fails like how
did I get this information to begin with
so let's go back to our previous example
of that call stack right so we run into
an invalid operation exception because
that product does not exist
so the product ID basically doesn't make
any sense now in order to understand
where we got that from we need to
understand where does this information
come from it basically came Upstream
right so we go up and we realize oh it's
due to that order packaged event being
published that we sent that update stock
message to begin with
but that's not that was just sort of
reaching over those ordered lines and
taking the information that was in there
so we need to go up further and see oh
it was when the order placed event was
published that those product IDs were
incorrectly mapped
now the thing is how do we solve such
problems in a distributed system well we
basically need to big picture we can't
really look at a sort of single
component to be able to catch these
larger problems because clearly this is
a simple example but imagine you know
that happening like 10 messages upstream
and then it becomes a lot more complex
so we need to be able to sort of follow
the business transaction through all of
those participating components right
that could be rest apis it could be
other components it could be messages
flowing through a message broker you
know anything you're getting from the
database and so forth and we also want
to include context for sort of each of
those individual steps that take part in
that business transaction as well
and that's exactly what distributed
tracing is for
so distributed tracing is getting like a
lot of attention lately probably due to
the rise of microservices but it's
actually not that new it's sort of
emerged in the late 2000s when a lot of
the things that we were talking about
was service oriented architecture still
right
now the thing is it that is that it
doesn't really matter which type of
architectural style that you are using
in your system because once you start
decoupling the system and you have
multiple components that are interacting
with each other you sort of need to be
able to understand how those components
are interacting with each other what
data is being passed along in which
order and so forth to be able to
understand these types of problems
so
okay our teams are like you know
distributed tracing we need to do this
and if you remember our teams operate
autonomously right they could choose
whatever tools Frameworks and whatever
it was that best suits their own needs
so they start looking at what's
available out there for distributed
tracing and they see wow there's
actually a bunch of Frameworks and tools
available for us to choose from
so what happens is that you have team
lorem that says let's use Jaeger and
then you have Team Epsom that says well
you know we're already using Azure
monitor application insights so we might
as well go with that one
and it's really problems like these
that made them Clash because what's
happening is that although each of those
teams are basically collecting very
useful instrumentation from their
systems the problem is is that stored in
a vendor-specific format
and it's problems like these that's that
sort of lead to a sort of higher need
for standardizations what do we then do
as an industry
create multiple standards right so we
have the cloud native Computing
foundation with their open tracing
specification for distributed traces and
around the same time frame Google open
source their open senses specification
which is a sort of standard for tracing
and metrics
and then as an industry we're good at
this right we always just keep creating
another standard until we have 15. but
this time these teams got together and
said come on let's get it together for
once right and try to sort of merge them
together and that's how open Telemetry
came to be so they basically looked at
each individual the sort of individual
strength of each specification merge
them together provided an upgrade path
for the previous users and took that
into account when working on open
telemetry
so what is open Telemetry exactly it's
basically a sort of Open Source
observability framework composed of a
set of tools apis and sdks and the sort
of goal of this project is that we can
basically standardize how teams
instruments analyze and Export Telemetry
information from their applications
it's also available across platform
cross runtime I think at this point it's
11 programming languages or something
like that so even if you're using
multiple Stacks you're probably covered
and
and the thing is I'm seeing
observability framework who's heard of
that word before observability
okay that's actually quite a lot but
it's quite a new terms I'm going to take
some time to explain it anyway right
because for software to be observable
right we need to understand the inner
workings of a system which means that we
need to understand any expected state
that the system may arrive to but also
any unexpected state right the unknown
unknowns
and you need to be able to do that
without changing any code deploying new
versions adding lock statements stuff
like that that's that's not what
observability is
the idea is that we're going to collect
information inside the application then
go store that outside of the application
and then we can use specialized tools to
sort of query and analyze that
information in order to get actionable
insights to go and improve our
application
so no going into your database and
querying things that's not really what
observability is right and open
Telemetry supports multiple ways of
increasing the observability of a system
it supports it supports three so-called
observability signals traces logs and
metrics and each of these are sort of
individual components that provide some
insight into what is happening inside
the application as well but I sort of
like to look at these as metrics or your
sort of known unknowns because if you're
capturing a metric then it's probably
something that you expect might go wrong
at some point
but you're probably going to have to
rely on your traces and your logs
whenever an unknown unknown is going to
occur in a production environment
so let's start with traces what is a
trace exactly well a trace is going to
track the progression of a request
across multiple components of your
system and I like to think of this as a
sort of business transaction that's
occurring in the system
is basically you could represent this as
sort of tree of spans and a span is
basically a single unit of work that is
occurring as part of that distributed
Trace could be getting a message off of
a broker could be querying for some data
it could be just a sort of expensive
calculation that is happening in the
system
and each of those spans and also carries
a context so think of that as sort of
key value pairs that give you a little
bit more insight into what is happening
in that specific unit of work what data
is being passed along what are we making
decisions based upon
that's a little bit abstract so let's
take a look at a visual representation
so as you can see
um the right the right that's basically
the same Trace ID for for all of those
spans so each individual colored block
is a span that is participating in that
larger distributed trace and as you can
see they're also being emitted by
different components right so they're
coming from different processes
different Services altogether
and if you sort of take a step back and
look at that you might think well that
looks kind of familiar because it's
basically a distributed call stack that
we've built
and it gets even better because what we
can do is we can sort of zoom in into an
individual span right that represents an
individual unit of work that took part
in that larger trace and we can take a
look at the sort of context that that
carried right so we can see here the
message ID which destination that was
being sent to and then some information
about the order as well we can also see
some events that were emitted as part of
that unit of work and that gives us a
lot more insight into what was happening
so to bring it back to the previous
example that I was completely unable to
the bug then what we would do is we
would go into our observability backend
and I'll talk a little bit about that
later and we would try to find field
spans and then the update product stock
spans would come up
and we would say okay those don't tell
us anything but at that point we can
sort of navigate up the tree to try to
understand where we can see some context
that looks of and that would then lead
us to that order place event where we
can basically see that the IDS were
incorrectly mapped
now the question is how does this tray
sort of work how does that get connected
across so many boundaries right because
we're crossing the network we're
crossing security boundaries how does
that work
well for that Trace to sort of be
connected therefore distributed we need
some kind of a propagation mechanism and
that usually happens through a
standardized protocol
and one of the protocols that's
recognized by the open Telemetry project
is a w3c trace context for HTTP headers
rolls off the tongue I don't know why
they make it so incredibly long
what it really does adds a transparent
header to every outgoing request looks a
little bit like this sort of
concatenation of multiple IDs but
looking at the hyphens they do have some
meaning so the first part is basically
the version of the protocol in this case
Zero the second part is a trace ID that
is going to be assigned when basically
the distributed Trace start and at that
point it's going to be copied by each
subsequent span that participates in
that distributed Trace
so that next section is a span ID that's
going to be unique for every span and
finally we have some Trace Flags to
indicate sampling decisions and things
like that
so if you're in the.net space
hence
almost anyone
then you want to get started with this
and Microsoft has made it easy for you
why because they built it into.net it's
available from.net 5 and onwards in the
activity API or if you're still running
on previous versions of.net or
godforbits.net framework there's still
plenty of very successful.net framework
applications running in production so
absolutely no shaving that then you can
just pull in the system Diagnostics
diagnostic Source nougat package to get
basically access to the same
capabilities
and it's pretty easy to sort of set up
tracing because the only thing you need
to do is select the sources from which
you want to collect instrumentation and
then set up a sort of exporter to then
send that Telemetry to an observability
backend
and you hardly really need to change any
code for that so let me show you a
snippet if you're using the.net generic
host could look as simple as this so I'm
basically pulling in the open Telemetry
extensions hosting package that makes
that ad open Telemetry method available
and then at that point I once I gave a
sort of very recognizable name to my
service because remember that that data
is going to be stored outside of the
application so you want to be able to
understand which specific component
emitted that information so make sure
that that's not bogus right and then you
want to collect you basically set up the
sources from which you want to collect
tracing information in this example and
then you set up you could set up
exporters like this this is the sort of
easiest way to do this what it means
that each individual service that is set
up this way will basically collect the
information
and immediately send it to the exporter
there are way more advanced scenarios to
set this up with the open Telemetry
collector but that's for another session
I hope to be back right
so if you're looking at the sort of
exporters that you could use or more
accurately the observability backends
there are multiple choices available
right the beauty of a standard is that
it doesn't really matter which specific
observability backend that you are using
right because that data is going to be
stored in they see in the same format so
whatever works for you whatever needs
you have within your team within your
system look at the right tooling and
just go with that
but before you start adding any
application specific tracing we need to
start looking at what's out there
because the community really has us
covered with this there's been a lot of
support for the open Telemetry project
it's actually the second most popular or
highest philosophy project after
kubernetes so it's pretty crazy
and if you look at you know what type of
uh you know a sort of Frameworks you
might be using in your application
you'll find that there's already open
Telemetry support for many of those and
if you sort of look at this and if you
think about the sort of challenges of
debugging distributed systems it's
usually that we have blind spot wherever
inter-service communication occurs but
if you just look at all the packages
that we have here we're already covered
right we have HTTP client asp.net core
grpc we we have any messaging libraries
that already have support for
instrumentation that would give us sort
of that insight and then we can go and
and enrich that information
now if you go and you start reading the
documentation the open Telemetry
specification documentation you look at
some.net documentation you're going to
get confused really quickly because they
basically are using different type of
language now why is that because
Microsoft already had a sort of tracing
API available the activity API and
instead of sort of creating a completely
new API what they did is basically
implement the open Telemetry
specification inside the activity API so
there's a few things that you need to be
aware of probably because they didn't
want to rewrite half of their own
applications right but if you see the
mention of a tracer in open Telemetry
that's an activitysource in.net a span
is represented by an activity span
context activity context and finally the
span attributes are tags on the activity
in.net if you're running in a sort of
multi-stack type of system and you
really want to keep the language the
same then there's also a shim available
that you can use but that requires
adding in another package
okay so before we actually look at the
code on how you sort of add tracing to
your application I want to take some
time and and sort of think through what
is the type of information that you
should be adding tracing for to begin
with
right and one of the examples that I
like to use is
how many times we close issues because
we can't reproduce them
who's ever closed an issue because you
can't reproduce them
I want to see every hand because
otherwise you're not being honest
or you fell asleep
we even have banners for it right it
works on my machine I have one on my
laptop
but imagine if you could easily connect
a specific user action to a trace and
say oh that was John Friday 3 P.M and
find the trace
then we could actually go back and look
at the friction that that user
experienced because I promise you they
were not imagining it right the thing is
that when users use a system they're not
paying attention to each individual
action that they're executing and sort
of looking at that order so when
something happens they're like what did
I do they'll just raise an issue with
the information that they remember
right but if we can just easily connect
that we can get the entire scope of
information to understand what occurred
another question ask yourself is how
easily can you sort of group similar
traces together things that stand out in
latency in specific attributes that they
carry so that you could sort of
understand what things stand out there
maybe in performance as well
okay you identify the most load
generating operations in your system
do they happen in a specific part of
your user base or do they happen maybe
at a specific time in the day are they
specific to a geographical location and
do you need to maybe scale out parts of
your infrastructure
can you identify which users are
stressing out your system what are they
doing and in which order are they doing
things why do they get to sort of create
that friction in the system as opposed
to other users
and finally how easily can you find
suspicious events throughout the systems
right is there someone doing something
funky or another completely utter
example let's say that you wrote a book
you're like okay may I cool but I'll fix
it deploy it and then someone from the
business walks up to you and says hey
Leila good that you fixed the bug can
you tell me how many customers were
affected by this
uh I don't know
observability could also help you sort
of answer those types of questions as
well so I look at these sort of
questions as seeds to plant in your
brain and I think what I would recommend
is that you come up with your own set of
questions and document them on what you
expect to get out of the Telemetry that
you are collecting from your application
so that we can also do this in a sort of
consistent Manner and get the same
quality of instrumentation across an
entire system multiple teams multiple
people working on it as well
okay
now we can finally look at some code so
if you want to start creating some
application specific traces in.net
you're going to need an activity Source
now that needs to be uniquely named
representing the component that's
submitting the Telemetry and you could
ask yourself whether you want to use
sub-components or use some kind of
configuration now think about the amount
of traces that you're emitting right if
there are any traces that you want to be
able to opt out from so you want list
sort of spans to be collected as part of
that distributed Trace then what you
would do is create an additional
activity source and you could maybe end
up with stock.core and stock.calculation
whoever wants a Telemetry from both can
just add source stock.star and you get
the both
if on the other hand you're looking at
no I want all of the spans but I want to
be able to to sort of opt out from
specific attributes for example that are
being collected then you're more looking
at configuration I'll give you an
example if you add for example at SQL
client instrumentation then you have a
configuration method available to say I
want to capture the database statements
or I don't right so that's an example of
configuration
and then basically you can create this
once as a static and share it inside
your components totally fine
now open Telemetry also works based on a
sort of opt-in model so it's not because
you're creating all of these traces and
that instrumentation that it's also
actually being collected you still need
to opt in how do we do that by adding
The Source right we say adsource stock
in this specific example and it's really
important that those string literals are
also going to match
when it comes to the sort of code that
we want to instrument and add some
insight to what I'm doing here is I'm
using that activity source that I
instantiated earlier and I'm creating an
activity based on that Source now that
gives me a nullable activity it's
basically a performance optimization
because like I said earlier the the sort
of the way that this API is implemented
is an opt-in model which means that if
nobody is listening I'm getting a null
reference so be careful and make sure to
add that question mark
I'm making use of the using statement
not only because I want to dispose of
everything correctly but also because
this will call stop activity for me so I
don't need to remember to do that and
stop the span exactly where you want it
to be stopped
and then you can add some tags in this
case or attributes in the open Telemetry
spec naming and that would be like if
you look at a piece of code right ask
yourself if I would be debugging this
what would be of interest to me like
what are the parameters that stand out
that could be impacting the decisions
that are being made within this piece of
code and that's something that you want
to consider adding in there
you can also add some events by the way
this is a terrible example would give me
an opportunity to talk about that
because if you were actually
recalculating this the stock you'd
create a dedicated span so you can also
see how long does that take and all of
that right but you could have whatever
sort of logging type of comment you
would add to events
and then I'm also catching any exception
that might occur why because I want to
set specific tags on that span or
activity to sort of signal to the
observability back end that this went
wrong this is also the perfect place to
sort of capture additional tags in case
you want some extra Insight that you
don't want to capture when everything
goes right but you only want to capture
that when things go wrong okay
don't forget to rethrow
now I also want to sort of quickly
Circle back to that
version right there because I skipped it
earlier not because I don't care but
because I thought it deserved its own
slide now why is that important because
as our code evolves so does the
instrumentation that it emits right so
it's important to make those versioning
changes explicit in your observability
backend because that will also be
visible when you are querying that
information remember that that
information is stored outside of the
application right and it might be really
interesting when sort of trying to
understand specific things that you're
observing in that data to understand
which version of that component that
information came from
it's okay our teams are doing this
they're like you know
this is really really helpful
and they start looking at this code and
they Wonder like
this looks a lot like logging
so then the question Rises of should we
stop vlogging all together and just
focus on distributed tracing instead and
this is sort of a complicated question
it's like the typical it depends answer
right because if you compare locks to
traces tracing really has a sort of
richest data model as opposed to logs
because you can add attributes you can
sort of connect those across multiple
components which is usually a very big
pain if you want to do that sort of log
correlation across multiple components
but on the other hand the open Telemetry
project is also working really hard on
making that sort of cross component log
correlation a lot more a lot more
yeah a lot better I guess so yeah what I
would say is if you are free to choose
and if it fits within the team that
you're working with then yes prefer
those distributed traces especially in a
distributed environment right but the
thing is that we have been logging for
years in our applications right and
there's no need to go back to your
manager and say okay I watched the stock
at NDC Oslo can you please give me two
months because I need to replace all of
our logs with traces no
don't do that right you can sort of
gradually sort of go and start using
traces where it makes sense and then
what is really really important is that
we sort of connect the traces and the
logs that we already have in our system
connect those together through sort of
cross signal correlation
and again if you're running into sort of
Microsoft stack super easy if you're
using the Microsoft extensions logging
framework because we can basically add
open Telemetry and what this this what
this is going to do is apply the open
Telemetry sort of logging format to any
log statement that is going to be
emitted from your application and then
I'm also setting up some exporter so
that I can collect that information
again in one of those observability
backends
now what is the result of doing
something like this
it looks a little bit like this and the
most important part in my opinion is
that it adds that Trace ID and that span
ID to every log statement that is being
emitted that means that it doesn't
matter what you're looking at if you're
looking at your logs you have the active
span ID in the trace ID available you
can go into whatever observability
backend that you're using for your
traces and go query for that and the
other way around as well if you're
looking at the traces you can find all
of the correlated locks as well and that
makes it really powerful to have that
sort of cross signal observability in
your system
so what about metrics because I've
talked about traces and I've talked
about logs but I haven't really talked
about metrics a lot well it's sort of a
sort of signal on its own right I do
want to drop a few sort of pointers but
basically their scalar values
accumulated over time to sort of
represent a specific state of the system
it could be message throughput right and
messaging is something that we really
like to look at
but it could also be the failure rate
right which then makes a very good base
for alert so if we have more than I
don't know 10 failures in a span of a
few minutes then I want someone to be
woken up major Duty alerts everywhere
could be something that you want to do
or emails or whatever it is
right so it's really good to sort of do
proactive monitoring now the thing is
with metrics is that you're only going
to monitor things that you can already
expect to go wrong and it's really an
indication of a problem but it doesn't
give you a lot of insight into what's
going on now there are things that we
can do to sort of improve that and that
is by doing metric correlation so that
we would capture what is called in open
Telemetry metric exemplars so basically
add some information to the metric that
we are collecting so that we would then
be able to connect that to the traces
and the logs that were emitted in that
sort of fed into that metric looking a
little bit out of whack
okay so I've told you all of these
glorious things about open Telemetry and
observability
and you might be thinking what's the
catch
and I mean there's multiple ones
because first of all there's going to be
some memory overhead in your
applications now
you need to be running at a massive
scale if this is what you care about
right in any sort of regular application
this is not something that you're
probably going to have to be concerned
about because these app these apis were
basically also created with performance
optimization in mind but if you're
running at a massive scale
there's going to be some memory overhead
there's also going to be some added
latency and some additional bandwidth
that you're using right because that
some information is being propagated
across services so you're adding some
headers here and there and then you're
also using additional bandwidth to send
that information to the observability
backend as well
there's also going to be a storage cost
because we have to store that data
somewhere and usually that's not free
and we're also introducing new tools
some of those might require a license
we also have to educate our team not
only to start you know creating traces
and logs and metrics inside the
application that's one end but also then
using those tools those uh to sort of
query those observability backends and
look at the information that we have
available to sort of extract actionable
insights that can help us go and improve
our applications
and then finally there's maintenance
because any type of code that we add to
our systems is going to evolve whether
that's production code or testing code
or in this case instrumentation code
right every letter of code is an added
cost and it's going to have to be
maintained by teams that are also
changing over time and it's a thing to
consider as you can see like I started
cheap and then it became more expensive
now
that doesn't mean that you shouldn't be
adding observability to a system right I
just spent an hour telling you that you
should but I just want to make you aware
that with whatever decision we make with
that whatever architectural style
whatever tools you introduce there's
always a trade-off that you are making
so it's important to be aware of those
as well
okay so if you decide to do this and
you're creating additional observability
in the system
you get additional benefits because what
I've been talking about for almost a
full hour at this point is really
failure investigation right so how are
we able to sort of understand the root
cause of problems in a larger systems
where components are communicating with
each other over messages or whatever
other communication pattern that you
might be using but there are plenty of
other benefits that you could get first
of all observability could be a driver
to basically understand where your
system is slow where you see higher
latency
how many times does someone walk up to
you and say the system is slow and
you're like okay
what is slow where is it slow what were
you doing
right but if we have added observability
in the system it would be easier for us
to sort of go query and understand where
that latency is when does it happen
because usually if we're running in a
development in a testing environment
everything is speed of light all the
time and then a production environment
things change and it's like okay what's
going on
it also gives you sort of the ability to
perform post-mortems yeah really dark
word but think of a sort of Black Friday
Cyber Monday right everything went kind
of okay system didn't completely come
crashing down thank God
but we also want to go back and reflect
and say okay how did this go can we
further improve this for next time right
maybe if we're running in the cloud we
are basically we have configurations
that allow us to Auto scale our services
so was that configuration good did we
scale up uh quickly enough or maybe even
more importantly that we scale back down
quickly enough so that we don't have
those massive bills right so this can
also give you that insight
another sort of possible benefit is
feature flagging let's say that you have
a very large system and you're adding a
feature to that system and you don't
want to go and release it to the entire
user base first of all you want to
release it some sort of segment of that
user base and then start to see
is this even being used and when it's
used do any exceptions pop up are there
any issues with that does it have a sort
of performance or latency impact on the
rest of the system so that we can sort
of understand how that's doing before we
go and release it to the entire user
base
finally we also have chaos engineering
right who's heard of chaos engineering
before okay plenty of hands well we now
have sort of services available like
Azure chaos Studio
chaos monkey and those sort of allow us
to sort of unleash Chaos on the system
push it to its limits and see where it
starts breaking first that's a sort of
really good strategy to increase the
resilience of a system and and see how
it could better sort of support our
production environments
but if you use a service like that
and you see a bunch of errors and you
have zero observability in your system
then how are you going to figure out
what went wrong and what needs to be
improved in order to not be in that same
situation when those when that chaos is
caused by your users in a production
environment
because without observability you're
going to be looking for lots of needles
in many many many many many many
Haystacks right
so okay we've sort of reached the end of
the session so we can slowly recap I
especially specifically when thinking
about failure investigation solving
issues in a sort of production
environment I like to think of
observability as a way to replace the
call stack that we gave up when we sort
of transitioned from a sort of
Monolithic architecture to a more
distributed architecture where there are
multiple components interacting with
each other
does that mean that you're never going
to have to debug again
nope but hopefully it will not be as
painful as what I sort of portrayed in
the beginning of this session right so
we'll add more tests we'll be able to do
that zoom out zoom in based on our
distributor tracing understand where
things are going wrong at tests there
and maybe that will require some
debugging here and there so it will be
localized and hopefully pain free
if you're ready to get started like I
said there's no need to go back to your
manager and say I need three months now
no we can just start by investigating
the instrumentation libraries that are
available out there for the Frameworks
that you're already using in your
application because you will see that
those already provide a lot of
visibility into what's happening with
the system even those spans that are
being emitted can be accessed through
activity.current and you can then go and
add some additional tags to those
activities to sort of further enrich
them even without adding any application
specific expense
and then connect all of that information
to your logs right one of the in my
opinion at least one of the sort of
advantages of the open Telemetry project
is their focus on Signal correlation
cross-signal correlation so we have
metrics logs and traces but being able
to connect all of that information
together is really going to give us the
maximum amount of value of that
observability in our system
and then slowly enhance and enrich from
there right take it slowly gradual
improvements until you get to the point
that is sufficiently observable for your
system to be running successfully in
production
okay uh that was it if you have any
questions I'm happy to hear them feel
free to scan the QR code it will take
you to one of my GitHub repos
repositories I have additional resources
there available for you also a sample
that you can run based on in service bus
if you have any questions feel free to
come and ask me and you can also find me
for the rest of the day at that
particular software Booth as well thank
you for listening
thank you